>>Coach Dick: I was a girls'
basketball coach here for 16 years,
and in the fall of '99, I found
that the school was
thinking about an EAST lab.
When my manager told me what
EAST was, I said, "Well,
what does the facilitator do?"
And he said, "Keeps kids off porn."
And so I thought, "Well,
I could do that."
>>Good evening, I'm Krystle Payne.
>>And I'm Logan Pratt and here
are tonight's top stories.
>>Coach Dick: And obviously,
it became much more than that.
It's the most innovative, educational
movement there has ever been,
in my opinion.
>>Both: And remember, stay in
class, EAST, and good night.
>>Coach Dick: I was old-school,
I was a science teacher,
and I decided what the kids were
going to learn, when they were going
to learn it, how they were going
to learn it, and which side
of the paper they were
going to put their names
on when they turned it in.
I was a little bit more of
a liberal basketball coach
and I didn't run a lot of set
offenses, but I was old-school.
I felt like I needed
to be in control.
And the concept of EAST did not
lend itself to that, and it was hard
for me to get over, but
it was also exciting.
>>You did good, people [Laughter]
>>Coach Dick: There's
a trigger, I think,
that clicks in where the students
realize the opportunity they have.
>>So, where do you want me to stand?
>>Coach Dick: Once they get into
a project and they see the results
of the project, there's
usually no holding them back.
They finish one.
They're ready to go on to another.
The beauty of EAST is we're
allowed to use real-world,
industry-grade technology to go out
and do projects, and if we fail,
we fail, but it's not like
they're out in the working world.
They have the opportunity to stretch
their legs and see what they can do.
These kids don't learn
something because they have to
and then put it back
on a test and lose it.
When they finish their
learning, they have it.
They take it with them.
>>And all those rooms
are the same size, right?
>>Yes.
>>Coach Dick: They understand
that what they're going out there
to do is going to be
used in the public.
It's going to be seen by
the public, and it's going
to be judged by the public.
That creates high expectations
in itself.
>>Cobra EAST students find new
creative ways to integrate technology
in their projects in order
to benefit the community.
>>Coach Dick: The Founder's
Award is an optional competition
that celebrates everything
that the lab does over a year,
and we have to do that into a
presentation that is informative,
concise, and, hopefully,
entertaining.
>>Cool! I don't think I need
to say anymore, do I [Laughter]
>>Coach Dick: These kids are
extremely hard on themselves
and critical, and when they come
out throwing high-fives and excited
and doubling over, you
know they've nailed it.
So this is one of my
special times, I'll tell you.
This is what I come to work for.
>>It's really great.
>>Go EAST [Laughter]!